what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 4 of the data science and data
analysis with Python and pandas tutorial
series in this video we're going to be
continuing off of the last video where
we got our basically our correlation
table and what we want to do in this
video is focus on visualizing that
correlation table and some of the other
things that are gonna come along with
doing that so to begin let's just get
basically where we were so import pandas
as PD import numpy as NP and at least to
start PD reads CSV and we can do data
sets min wage dot CSV and then we want
to do like that act min wage in that
loop I think it would be this loop here
right just want I don't want to yeah
that was all just confirmation of what
was the problem so really just this
right here copy that so this is from the
previous tutorial and then we want to
set the min wage core here
so this be get this becomes our min wage
core and it's not dot head that's like a
typo really and then min wage court
ahead okay cool so this is our
correlation table now we want to graph
it so if you haven't already open up
terminal command prompt pip install
matplotlib but if you've been following
the series you've already done that
this would be a hard series to jump in
randomly so I'm gonna assume everybody's
cut the things we've installed so far so
first of all with matplotlib we just go
we're just gonna do import mat plot mat
plot bread Lib dot pie plot as PLT and
then we can do PLT mat show and we're
just gonna match show that data frame so
min wage
or and that should be enough Oh
PLT - we probably have to call P LTS
show in here yeah okay mmm
so okay that got us pretty far pretty
quick pretty simple unfortunately as
you'll find with is the case with
matplotlib all the time you really are
gonna likely need to do a lot of
customization so if you want to we can
come into here I don't even know how to
navigate my own site apparently there we
go data vis coming here and you can
learn all the stuff about customizing
matplotlib if you want I'm not gonna
spend too much time on that but we are
gonna do at least some customization
here just to make this work because I
feel like one the colors are wrong - the
labels being numbers means nothing to us
it's not helpful it's not helpful
visible visualization so how can we make
this a little better well right out of
the gate I would think okay hey here's
what we could do we could say labels
equals and then just do a list
comprehension so C for C in min wage
core I see the issue there anyway at
columns and then fix this and then let's
just do like the first two letters so
that would be like the first it's gonna
be a long day
okay so so this would be like you know
if it's Alabama al Michigan mi and so on
so we could do something really basic
like that and then let's fix some of the
other things so fig equals P LT dot
figure and then figs size will be will
just make this a 12 by 12 so if you want
to start customizing matplotlib you have
to kind of even pull it out even further
so first of all we've pulled we've
stopped you well in this case we
actually didn't do like dot values or
anything we just passed the entire data
frame and it works so that's great but
then if you want to start modifying
things you can't modify PLT you have to
modify an axis well to have an axes you
have to have a subplot
to have a subplot you need a figure so
so we have our figure now we want to do
our
see so we're gonna say axes equals fig
dot add subplot and in here I'm going to
pass 1 1 1 what this means is this is a
1 by 1 let's say the figure all the
subplots on the figure are in a 1 by 1
grid and this is number 1 so this just
means there's gonna be one graph now
what we want to do is a X dot Matt show
and we want a Matt show min wage cor but
then we also want to change the C map
this that's color map and the C map we
want to use here's PLT cm cm dot red
yellow green and now we have that we we
could just go ahead and just do this
real quick and boom now it's a heat map
it looks more like what we would expect
and but our ticks aren't really labeled
yet so that's the next thing we want to
do so the next thing we would want to
say is a x dot set underscore set
underscore Y tick labels and we want to
pass labels and then we'll do the exact
same thing here and we we probably want
to do that before the show can I get
away with that oh I said do X&Y ok ok
cool so we have the labels here but we
don't have all of them so matplotlib is
kind of truncating them because it
doesn't want to put too many labels on
an axes make it hard to read if these
were numbers then this would be probably
descriptive enough for us but they're
not numbers and it's not so what we need
to do is tell matplotlib hey show me all
of them so the next thing we were we can
do here is we can actually just tell
Matt pot Lib show all of the labels and
the way that we can do that ax dot set
underscore and then X ticks and then
we'll use numpy dot range and that will
be for the Len
of labels LaBelle's and we'll do the
exact same thing for y XY boom nope why
didn't that work why didn't that work
[Music]
why isn't that working hold on everybody
why tick labels label match so so maybe
we will we'll set the match show first
and then do the modifications yeah so
I'm guessing that even after we set this
then we did this and it like reset it
for whatever reason so first do the
match show then modify the ticks and I
bet we can't do a show now right like
that'll still be messed up or would it
and what's up with the text fascinating
okay whatever we'll do this way okay
great so that's looking pretty awesome
now what well if we look it's probably
really hard to see here but like what if
I just print labels out we can see we
actually have quite a few overlapping
that are like the same name like MI and
mi so Michigan Minnesota and any any any
like four or five NES here that's kind
of a problem so maybe we want to
actually make these right so we could
hard code them ourselves because we
might actually know them or we could
bring in outside dataset so a lot of
times in this case we only have like 39
states that I actually had minimum wage
data so we could totally fill that in by
hand but later you might find you have a
data set that's much larger and then
you've got like some sort of values that
you actually want to map that data set
and it would just be very cumbersome to
do by hand so how could we fix this well
first we need to find we need some way
of mapping the state name to
- you know I get to letter thing so the
first thing I would do is just go online
and look for one right so state brie vs
so I would start by here and then
basically I stink I started yeah I found
ended up finding this one I think I
started here and then I eventually led
to this one so this was the first one I
found but we can't use pandas to pull
from here because this website actively
declines robots so then I found info
please calm and this one does not
yes we can overcome anything that you
know tries to decline access to a robot
that's not a problem I did problem I
have is making a tutorial on doing that
to a specific website I think you could
run into certain issues if you do that
so I'm going to avoid doing that so we
use this site instead because this site
does not block bots so cool so that's
the one that we want to use now so let's
go ahead and read in that data so the
first thing that we would do is we would
just you might have this in a separate
script so I'm just going to write
everything out again import pandas as PD
especially because this could cause we
might have issues with this in a little
bit and then what we want to do is DF so
DF s equals PD dot read HTML and don't
run this yet
and then that website that we just found
it's like info please calm I'll put
either the link in the description or
the text base tutorial in the
description and you can find the link
there or you could just Google exactly
how I did in find that one super simple
now to use read HTML we need a few
packages we need L XML html5 Lib and
beautifulsoup before so come to a
command prompt pip install html5 live
actually let me just do it in order L
XML html5 Lib B s4 so go ahead and
install those if you are on Mac you will
need to run an extra command go to the
text-based version of the tutorial to
figure that out if you're on like some
sort of company computer with some sort
of proxy system
what you're gonna want to do is also pip
install requests you might as well have
requests as well as a much smarter way
of accessing the Internet so go ahead
and grab that - even if you're not our
proxy so normal people should be able to
just run this and get a return but when
I run this I get this nasty red nonsense
about an SSL certificate fail so to
overcome that mmm
instead I'm going to import import
requests and then do a Rick actually
I'll just say this I'll say web equals
requests I get and I'm gonna get this
paste that in there and then we'll read
HTML web run that oh could not read
requests I get really I can't decide if
I need to like restart the kernel
because I just installed this stuff or
or what PT dot read HT Oh Momo Momo okay
yeah okay so actually what we need to
say is web dot dot txt what I need to
say is what it takes right okay great so
but again if you aren't having issues
you probably need to do this if you
continue to have SSL certs issues you
could also say verify equals false in
the request not yet for some reason I
was getting a certificate issue with
read HTML but not requests despite
requests verifying the SSL certificate
by default I have no idea what's going
on there but anyway cool so we have data
frames ax so what pandas read HTML does
is it will parse that website and and
then return a list of data frames based
on all of the tables it finds so even if
it only finds one table it's still a
list of that one data frame so for
example for DF n DF sprin DF head and
you can see here that we get two data
frames one is clearly states the other
one is like territories which we
we have in our minimum wage data
probably Puerto Rico and Guam but for
now we're gonna be focused on the main
one which will be DF DF 0 so what I'm
gonna say is state AB for abbreviation
equals DF 0 then we'll say state oops
dot head ok great hmm so that's exactly
what we want we want State and then we
actually don't want the abbreviation we
want the postal code right we want the
two-letter thing so what I want to do
now is just in case we have issues with
this like a lot of times if I have I'm
writing a script that gets information
from the web I really probably just want
to run that one time just in case that
website decides I've made too many
requests or you know whatever so while
we're at it we might as well just save
this so states AB dot to CSV and then
we'll save that as datasets and we'll
make that state have CSV now a couple
things to think about when you save
things to a CSV remember a CSV so
unpatentable Eve's
as it should your index is meaningful so
when you save something to a CSV file
CSV does not understand anything's in
index so when you save you want to say
like I'm trying to I can't even fully
remember it's like either indict I think
index equals false on save so pandas to
CSV and then when you read it in I want
to say it's just index call so yeah
index default is true so when we go to
save this it's gonna assume it wants us
to save the index so let's say we do
that then we read it back in state and
dots or equals PD to read CSV and
actually let's just read this in when we
go to read this in suddenly stay
head suddenly what we have is two of
these columns and as time is gonna go on
it's only going to keep getting bigger
and bigger and bigger so if you are
consistently saving and reloading some
sort of data set this will cause trouble
so instead what you want to do is is in
one or the other you know one way you
could say is you could say index call
equals zero and every time we read this
in 0 1 2 3 4 will always be your index
call alternatively we could even say
here index equals false save that now
the index data won't even be saved so we
could do this and it looks yet again the
same or we could even go even further
and say index call equals 0 and boom now
we just have the state abbreviation in
postal code so there's you know a
million ways that we can do this thing
that we're trying to do so the next
thing I want us to do is go ahead and
convert this to some sort of meaningful
dictionary so the way I'm going to say
that is AB dict equals States AB and
then what we want to say is the only
column we're actually interested in here
is postal code again don't forget double
square brackets otherwise it's gonna
treat it like a series and then we say
dot two dict underscore there dot two
dict and now let's just do AB Dix real
quick boom so now we have pretty much
what we want but it starts with postal
code so so I'm gonna say AB dict
equals a dict postal code now let's
print AB Dix okay now that is a
dictionary that we can easily map to a
column so now let's just try yeah we'll
just say this we'll say actually we
don't
to map it to a column we could just say
labels equals equals and then it'll be
AB dict C or C and min wage cor dot
columns try that out okay we don't have
federal FS or whatever so what we need
to do is just set a new value in our AB
dict
and we'll just add this in really quick
we'll just say that I always do that and
why did you just do that to me
only we're going to say that equals FLSA
a that's fine
okay and then we'll run this again
okay Yeah right now we're missing Guam
and we'll be missing Puerto Rico so
let's just fix both of those as well
while we're at it
glum and put the rego and that should be
a GU and that should hopefully be the
only hard coding we have to actually do
cool okay now we have labels so then we
come up here take this code here copy
that code come on down price should I
use page down but that's all right
paste in our new calculation for labels
and show our beautiful new graph now we
don't have the overlap egde everything
has the proper name that looks pretty
good we did it okay so I think that's an
okay stopping point and we've actually
covered quite a bit with like the read
HTML and fixing a bunch of stuff and
yeah
so pretty cool so I think in the next
tutorial what I'd like to do is we have
minimum wage data we can begin to like
compare data sets and like look at data
between multiple data sets and try to
derive meaning in some some way we're
probably not going to find out anything
too spectacular but it'll give us a good
opportunity to just kind of bring in
more outside in different data sets that
actually aren't even
from the saying because it's like
sometimes you're gonna find you've got
one data set from over here and it's
like from one totally different provider
they've got another one and then
sometimes they're not even organized by
either maybe not the same index or a
different type of index or like a
different granularity and so on so
anyways we're gonna get a little Messier
in the next video
maybe contain that all in one and then
hopefully right after that we'll get
into doing some machine learning just
real basic example of machine learning
with pandas so anyways that's it for now
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support the subscriptions the donations
the memberships all the good stuff and I
will see you guys in another video